greeting some podcast Vil the church is
brought to you by athletic greens if
you're not starting a day off with a
blast of vitamins you're already lost go
back to bed and [ __ ] and stay there all
day but if you want to feel tip-top
Magoo let it let it greens do the dirty
work they got you covered in five
critical areas you're ready health
energy and merely gut health and
hormonal support who takes care you like
that nobody so do me a favor the church
family gets a special offer we're gonna
give you 20 free travel packs valued at
$79 with your first purchase jump over
athletic greens calm / shirt si-hu rch
to get your travel packs today that's
athletic greens dot-com / church the
church is also brought to you by let me
ask you something how are you
comfortable life insurance you probably
sitting there scratching your head low
it Joey what's life insurance what
happens if you slip on a [ __ ] banana
peel and your kids still has to go to
school if you're not covered already
but life insurance on the top of your
to-do list policy genius makes it quick
and easy find the right life insurance
at the best price so listen don't be a
schmuck of any life insurance head to
policy genius calm and when it takes a
few minutes to find the right policy
insurance policy apply and have another
thing crossbow for your list for 2020
policy genius when it comes to life
insurance it's nice to get it right and
tell them the church or what's happening
now said [ __ ] it's got a beautiful
[ __ ] day to be alive kick this
[ __ ] mealy nice best thing of all
times might be nice
professor what's happening you bad
[ __ ] man just do my thing 3:00
in the morning always meant for three
days a week over there
I teach 20 classes a week that's my
full-time job is so like you know so you
keep you teach seven kind of about
classes a week
no I teach six six so like I teach one a
day over there and the rest is all
jiu-jitsu so Monday Wednesday and Friday
it's 5:30
lehder is at night is that nice 6:30
Saturday at 10:00 a.m. yeah
and then the Jitsu you know we have like
we have a ton of people over there so I
teach the rest is all jujitsu classes
then I have a couple private clients as
well you still do the basics though I
dunno if I do most of the fundamentals
my morning jujitsu classes are like all
levels in the end then at noon I do a
fundamentals class well professor
Alberto teaches the advanced and then in
the evening I do a couple fundamental
classes as well so most of the time I'll
do most of the fundamentals me and
Josiah you know Josiah oh and your boy
Marco - Marco he's teaching his son the
fun so the fundamentals are now 6:30 and
7:30 8:30 is now like a [ __ ] expert
class well they're splitting it up now
because we have we have a lot more black
belts now and we have more students so
we have to accommodate everybody man
like you know we have people who are
advanced but can only train it like 8:30
you know I mean so I mean it's good so
you can we split the classes up now so
we just have all kinds of class so then
you got to go on the schedule is just
too many to thought about it is it's
crazy
I saw sauce graduation class is insane
man it's [ __ ] insane it's insane how
many students we have there now it's
[ __ ] dope and when it comes to
Burbank North Hollywood all this appear
he's got the main lunchtime class man
you know it honestly dude I don't know
another gym in LA that is has as many
students as I have a drunk does he I've
never been drunk
I would love to train with Sean Sean I
would love the change I got I got my
black belt from his brother Roger John
John's got a great lunchtime
yeah I'm talking about in general
altogether though it's crazy because our
legacy is like popping from like 5:00 in
the morning to like cooking the evening
man it's crazy it's amazing like
professor Alberto has really done it
like created kind of like a little mecca
of jiu-jitsu and fitness out there now
so we have I remember when he was when
Justin fortune was his boxing that's I'd
never met just unfortunate but I know a
lot of people who've trained that's how
I stats how I reacted with Alberto in
New Mexico when I was shooting along
this yard
goddamn and then I connected with him
that was a long time ago because he
2004 Wow we used to all go me I'm in
Salaberry Bob's having salad her and I
got Bobby Bobby that Bob side Maurice
Smith I would all go to our Burroughs
because it was close to the hotel I bet
you half the people listening right now
don't even know who Maurice Smith is
yeah this is badass kick box oh man he
was the first guy to solve the puzzle
man like you know like he learned how to
scramble back to his feet instead of
like getting to a jujitsu match assume I
took him down he would just wait to
stand up and then kickboxer after
already fought Mark Coleman you know I
wouldn't fight I didn't watch fighting
that crazy I didn't even know Joe Rogan
back then yes I knew Joe I know Joe
since 98 and they would talk to me then
I met Eddie - Joe huh and I would get in
the car with them and I'm taking them
out it's not on coke my dick sucked and
there I'm dead talking about you Jesus
weeps and I'm like what the [ __ ] did you
do to sweep I came from the 70s where
you sweat well this before joey karate
this is before Joey karate and this is
before Eddie Abu Dhabi even dreamt of
going up with Doc Eddie up without the
combi so Jarrow and Eddie with training
partners okay lock that back down and
they would that you do you couldn't shut
him up you couldn't there elephant and
they're relatively new to it they were
Eddie was already Eddie my fingers of
brown bone okay and Joe was like a blue
belt I'm Joe went every day and that's
all they talked about and it was [ __ ]
annoying is flat but it was educational
being around something they would and
then they would talk about you know I
was raised in traditional martial arts
Nietzsche I was raised and it's time
when Bruce Lee was you know that was you
know the game ran on the streets you
know and you [ __ ] broke boards and
you hit the [ __ ] [ __ ] did all that
little pads that they were old and you
weren't real if your knuckles one man
what bust it up oh yeah yeah calluses on
my calluses because whatever my [ __ ]
thing is called
makiwara Makarov you know you know you
know it's funny you say that is a I had
a pleasure of training next to Dan
Inosanto you know Dan Asano like I did a
Muay Thai camp like back in the mid 90s
and he's telling us Bruce Lee's stories
and one of the things he told us about
Bruce Lee is that he never stopped
working out and he said he had one of
those Maquis roars or whatever you call
it in this looking car
he just be [ __ ] hittin that
[ __ ] in the car or he'd be
bouncing Brandon off his abs doing ab
workouts weddings watching TVs like he's
like he'd never stop I've been working
out man but yeah like uh my master used
to have wooden floors so we should do
our push-ups on her knuckles so then I
had [ __ ] calluses on my first two
knuckles and I mean that [ __ ] would like
strike fear and the people people would
like to look at my knuckles and be like
that was it you hadn't have your
knuckles [ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah I grew
up on the whole G [ __ ] grew up under
that and then I got out of karate at 16
I want a different direction but I met
Rogan like at 36 or something and
they're talking about this you have seen
I put on this is [ __ ] looks like he
hasn't stopped eating cheeseburgers in
20 years again some other guy that looks
like just got out of prison
yeah yeah this is [ __ ] disgusting you
know and like I I think I watched to it
remember that they weren't I was living
in Denver when all of the UFC's would
start only Colorado let you go oh yeah
yeah yeah back for sure back then my
friends wouldn't shut up about ya like I
said I watched one time I saw some big
fat guy and like a body suit and I said
some guy in like prison [ __ ] stripes
knows this is a martial arts and joke
yeah and they would talk about it
continually you know our relationship
bruised friends Eddie went to Abu Dhabi
opened up the hammer house his first
school and then he opened up I was at
with Mark Coleman no no he opened up on
Santa Monica I don't know what it was
what do you listen to me for I'm so
alleged bomb squad bomb squad to play
you're right
damn League up bomb squad and then they
moved through the Brea
the between Hollywood and sunset next to
that disgusting Thai restaurant well
well in there one time with them I
wasn't he is that when he partnered up
with like bas Rutten and Randy Couture
and yes Chris Chris Chris Riley he used
to coach rampage yeah he was a Muay Thai
coach are you so upset about this ever
you talked about this Thai restaurant I
was next door and I was I was minding my
own business so I lived on the corner of
that school oh yeah you guys we used to
live right down there I lived in
Hollywood I lived on between I live
between Hollywood and sunset on Selma ah
and there were nice nothing to do early
and I would walk through the whatever
that was on the corner there a Thai
restaurant no ten plan our Tampa next
door was the Thai restaurant and one day
I go where is that in there like the
next durian Thai food and I go next door
I sit down they reading that discussed
[ __ ] waiters with slippers on and
[ __ ] Drive feet I'm [ __ ] getting
aggravated and all of a sudden of no of
my aggravation just a compliment what I
was thinking a roach fell from the table
and it landed on its back so it was a
little claws ha ha ha hold you
[ __ ] not to eat this filthy
food and I got uh I got up and walked
out and that was my whole that was the
whole and I was sitting there going that
fried rice looks good what I can't do it
I'm working money you're like real
particular about that kind of like
Chinese I'm what the Chinese do with you
first the Chinese were here first and I
got here from Cuba it was Chinese
restaurant area
all of a sudden Thai and tsunami
Ethiopian food they tell me I take my
shoes off that in a restaurant that's
just think fast want your white people
would stink you feet that have you
showered all day let's take our shoes
well you take your [ __ ] shoes I know
what my 15 feet smell like ain't taking
my shoes off because he's gonna get an
ID you know why you're trying to eat
while somebody's [ __ ] try to eat when
somebody's
the brown one in the air like it's at
that light [ __ ] so that's how well I
know Eddie so when they would talk about
jiu-jitsu then they would get to the
point where they would travel in packs
and we would go do comedy and half the
economy they would clean out the [ __ ]
front and Eddie would wrestle somebody
from the staff that was like a purple
belt in Arizona hmm
how do I mean lights I didn't take Kate
Fletcher okay it would be me Eddie
Redmayne re-tape Duncan and Joe paid
Ferrari and Duncan to take jiu-jitsu hmm
so everybody was taking jiu-jitsu except
me and they'd be on that hallway [ __ ]
fight until the death furniture I'm with
the Tempe improv one night it was
[ __ ] tremendous and then we go to San
Francisco a little Denny would show up I
still I know little Denny when he was
too young to come to the club he was 16
he's the one that used to run ten pilots
San Francisco I still remember him being
a 16 year old kid and I sneaking them in
through the back door and me going on
stage bring him Rogen up and going back
to the San Jose greenroom and they'd be
wrestling shoes would be off man like
yeah they were like when I first got it
did you just sit back in man I'm like
mid-90s in South Carolina there's no
judges from South Carolina I stopped to
drive to Virginia Beach to train with
the blue belt and then I'd go back and
get one of my Taekwondo buddies or
Hapkido buddies and show them what I
knew and then we'd [ __ ] find piece of
carpet somewhere or wherever to flip
them just train wherever around because
you know there was no mats or I would go
to what jujitsu school judo gym or
something like that where they had mats
and just roll with those cats like that
you know so that's when you're so
enthusiastic about it you don't [ __ ]
give a [ __ ] you just train wherever you
just can't stop thinking about
especially like if you've been a a
traditional martial artist like us and
then you know you have black belts in
these martial arts and then you're
getting choked out by jujitsu people you
like what the [ __ ]
it's just like you know just a little
ice karate and yeah it's like wow man so
then that I remember I was just obsessed
and just roll anytime you could you know
but now I've been doing it for 30 years
who I hurt calm down a little bit but I
still loved you Jitsu before I hurt
myself I had enrolled for about two
weeks I just do privates with this guy
he's a little older and I mess around
with him I got to the point where you
know when I went to our Burroughs I love
that [ __ ] I just
my breathing but jiu-jitsu opened up my
eyes to how bad a shape I really was
like a little my eyes too it opened up
my eyes to the final flight response
which we know what happened yeah so much
fly the flight response used to be that
much that's what you live yeah yeah you
didn't want to put a gun to your ribs
you got fly the Fonz I had to fight like
a mother families I'm like yeah yeah
well they kick down the door and I'm
looking at I know for a fact professor
Joey has a kilo in this house and I'm
searching through [ __ ] you know your
flight or flight response is there you
learn to just share sure you go death if
you're really a [ __ ] real guy you go
death if I know Joey parks the car at
7:00 and walks down whatever to go get
the Train overhead North Hollywood and
manly are gonna jump you buy whatever
those three minutes before you get there
if I do my job right I should be going
deaf hmm
I should hear your steps coming very
softly before he in there what's that
adrenalin starts shining like it's good
addressing man you know what got me
pretty good help my fly the fight
squatting squatting like what do you
mean heavyweights I almost quit there
and I go yeah you can't solve walked for
three minutes straight yeah man we got
it got control your breathing then and
you have breathing that's why I tell it
like like when it comes to adrenaline
like like I remember my first fight my
first professional fight I was in TJ and
and they had us all in one room it
worked
we're all like what the [ __ ] my
opponents over there we're like what's
going on here man and then I had this my
friend Juan his girlfriend was like how
do you feel how do you feel how are you
gonna win are you gonna do this and I
was just feeling waves of adrenaline
whoa
whom and it was like I felt like I was
just gonna like [ __ ] flip out man
and then my instinct kicked in and I
just started controlling my breathing
like controlling cuz you if you don't
control your heartrate then then your
adrenaline will work against you you
know I mean that's why a lot of people
like gas out when they go when they find
in the UFC because they they let the
adrenaline get to them they blow their
wad you know you've seen that a hundred
times in UFC so like I remember how to
control my breathing so it's all about
your breathing man you if you can
control your breathing then you could
use your adrenaline to your advantage
you not I mean
and then your instincts just kicking it
it's so funny like I got jiu-jitsu I can
breathe yeah oh yeah my nose face so you
got your nose fixed got my nose fixed I
mean not for vanity reasons yeah because
you can when they go in there clean take
everything out that old cocaine rock the
wall of cocaine in my nose I could
[ __ ] breathe then I got a doctor
beliefs it came on here she has a book
called breathe not really help ya now
she recently sent me breathing for
athletes I just have not had a chance to
crack a [ __ ] book in six weeks I'm
supposed to write a review for her and I
don't want to write a fake review I want
to read the book and get some out of it
yeah yeah yeah yeah but I had to read
like you know herb thing as you breathe
naturally
okay it was funny my daughter came in
handy a day and she's to punch that
thing for three minutes straight and
when she finished dice goes look at it
she's not even breathing at me my
daughter goes to Muay Thai you know they
have had gear her breathing is the way
you should breathe gotta breathe it all
happens when you're 14 or 15 like a
traumatic experience and your breathing
deteriorates and there's what it says in
our book please
and this is why bas Rutten invented that
breathing machine so I connected him and
her and vos together because they had
something hmm that breathing piece when
I'm typing I put it in my mouth huh and
it helps it my you just put it in and
breathe as I'm typing yeah we're an hour
I'll [ __ ] breathe with that thing
do different exercises people do
actually [ __ ] did you do with that
yeah it really helps you because it it
closes the hole so you learned how do
you think more air in your lungs
we don't think more because people roll
man and you know I have to remind people
all the time I was like this and then
you gotta breathe that's where you guess
not I see you're holding your breath
even like when I'm training training
with people with the kettlebells you
know you got to make sure everybody's
breathing so there's different ways to
like I mean I've known about breathing
since like my mouth my Taekwondo man how
Keitel master taught us how to breathe
you know you got to breathe in through
your nose out slow your heart rate down
all that [ __ ] you know so it's important
has to be circle I found I practiced a
very simple Bria tick you just breathe
in through your nose out through mouth
slowly really slow and then like you
could do it different ways you can
breathe in like four five seconds
breathe out for five seconds and then
you can start increasing it though the
way you slow your heart rate down is by
through your breathing it's very simple
and people have different techniques and
stuff like that but it's I've been doing
that for forever man it works for me you
know first month I did yeah man yeah
yeah absolutely
you know Kosta phobic with aggi on Marco
looser anxiety Marco the purple Bob huh
his anxiety so bad when he gets on a
plane he passes out no no and that's the
point right
I pass out so was something that was
passed on for me from my mother to me oh
wow when she hurts herself when you pick
her up she loses consciousness you got a
shaker oh wow she just felt a couple
weeks ago at the park off the zipline
and [ __ ] she hurt her back
I hit her pretty hard and I had to pick
her up and hold her and I told you know
and I stole their data talk to ya it's
something like I didn't know what it was
there was no anxiety when I was 12
people do people have anxiety you didn't
know what it was if you have to feel
them that but I get them it I can I live
in anxiety what do you think happens to
me five minutes before I go onstage
oh yeah that's normal though man because
you're about to perform
it's not normal it's not moment what I
get you're supposed to have butterflies
butterflies yeah that's number fear not
the [ __ ] I get when I get this [ __ ]
that's telling me to quit like get in
the car right now
oh yeah you did enough yeah you know a
man died as many jiu-jitsu matches and
professional MMA fights I have even like
if I'm gonna compete did you just a
tournament on the way there I'm like
what the [ __ ] am i doing I'm like what
do I do
oh really you start quit yeah I start
talking to myself right I'm like listen
man I'm like Joey what are you thinking
you've had 100 jiu-jitsu matches you
know jiu-jitsu what are you worried
about I'm like I keep to have to keep
telling myself but it did get really bad
towards the end of my MMA career though
because I was getting my ass kicked you
know and after a while I was it was just
the anxiety was getting to me to the
point where I [ __ ] looked like [ __ ]
in the cage and I just wouldn't buy it
no it's just like okay I'm done I had
three three losses in a row but the
anxiety with MMA got to the point where
it was having a really negative effect
on my fighting you know I wasn't like
believing myself but do Jitsu is it's a
little bit different I know I'm not
gonna get punched in the [ __ ] face
and [ __ ] like that and I say what the
secret is professor tell me the secret
it's got to do a lot with breathing
absolutely what the secret is mindset
absolutely man you know like the secret
is how you look at things you know what
you know what I haven't best set on my
life two things I don't give a [ __ ] I
love to come up with a joke that stays
that insult you that much that I laugh
once I do that I'm not gonna yeah yeah
yeah after show the first two times I
drove to our boroughs I parked and I
said one of my crazy I pulled away I
could imagine when I walked into our
boroughs the fear was God for the first
three months it was like I can't believe
I'm gonna do this but I had to turn my
mindset around I had to look at it as I
was going down a have fun true exactly
people but yeah when I'm on top of you
when I fart my mistake
what's do we left and I'm right now I
got you professor get off me you smell
of you yeah laughs like what happens is
is you build it up
build it up to the actual problem you're
like what am i doing I'm just [ __ ]
going here to learn and oh my god as I
was putting my ghee on I'm thinking I'm
gonna get a hug yeah yeah people do all
the time trust me see like one girl one
time and you know the gyms packed and
she's just she's like this in the gym
holding her purse and I had a comment I
was like hey you okay she's like oh hey
it's okay we're gonna take care of you
man I think we're just gonna train you
know you're like they get scared cuz
it's intimidating you're going into
school with a bunch of [ __ ] guys
choking [ __ ] and [ __ ] like I
get it you know but but it's really up
to the people at that gym to make you
feel welcome yeah sometimes I've had a
[ __ ] show at 7 o'clock the cause
wouldn't pick me up with a quarter to
7:00 I'm in a strange town pick a town
I'm in [ __ ] Dallas I have been
onstage twice at the Comedy Store I
wrote all week to prepare my mind the
day of the show I actually sat down and
wrote something opposite jokes to get
creativity hmm and then an hour before
the show I look at my material I make
some last things then I smoke a joint I
go on the shower and I sit for 30
minutes and that's where I get you know
oh [ __ ] I put this here I bang one out
you [ __ ] dry off you get ready for
the show
right then and there is where the fear
starts hmm the car ride to the gig once
I get to the theater it's all pure fear
yeah yeah yeah well I can't agree and
I'm like bro when I walk into the green
rather way I gotta walk a hundred steps
a hundred yards or two yards and you
gotta hear my breathing it feels like
yeah so that's when you knit everybody
to start controlling your man right
there is my gonna regulate it I start
breathing I sit I drink water and that's
what I have to start doing what I you
know when I write that [ __ ] and I run a
day on Facebook that's how I actually
think yeah because if I let me think I
would think I'm a [ __ ] I would say to
myself if my post would be why get
stay in bed it's hot out there nothing's
gonna happen no you got to think the
opposite grab a knife washing wolfs
somebody's going to suck it if
somebody's up his thirsty collect
somebody's I've been dying the suckin
dick and you got tap on the menu you
don't but you're right about them the
mindset is everything one of the things
like I like like what will happen to me
with the arm the MMA is you know I'd
come out and I see a big crowd of
[ __ ] people not just like cold [ __ ]
and I'll start [ __ ] [ __ ] my pants
you know that's what started happening
more towards the end of the career and
then I saw like like Conor McGregor was
commentating there shone like a like a
montage of his fights and he was
explaining what was going on and then he
was like you see right here he was
coming out and everybody's booing him
he's like you see that [ __ ]
they're all [ __ ] boo me because I
[ __ ] love that because it's passion
and he goes I use that I turned that
into positive energy and I was like yes
mana that's what you gotta [ __ ] do
man cuz you know that's what you're
there to fight man he turned a negative
into a positive and that's an honesty
that gave us one of his strongest traits
is his mindset because mines his mindset
I mean the guy's a [ __ ] billionaire
now look what he [ __ ] is done you
know I mean so that's something I really
admire about people who fight in the UFC
and are successful men you know how
strong people don't look at what you
have to go through mentally to fight
like that you're about to fight in
foreign millions of people man it takes
it takes balls and takes a lot of mental
preparation and that's where your coach
comes in your coach if you have a good
coach they should be preparing you
mentally me back then there were no MMA
schools so we were like self trained and
I had my students would be cornering me
you know and they'd be just as scared as
me they'd be like oh [ __ ] you know but
the mindset is it's it's key it's so
funny how this people who are good
there's people who you ever hear those
guys are coming to your seat and it's
like their first fight you're seeing
people like we've been hearing about
these guys to Jim he said hey America's
top team just close to everybody there's
people who would gym fighters yeah yeah
absolutely in this gym phone that was me
how the gym bag going to the [ __ ]
arena they see 2,000 people
[ __ ] yeah man let me give let me flip it
let me flip the yard on you yeah
tremendous in the economy store original
tremendous I keep going and go nine out
of ten ten times in a row because I know
the nooks and crannies okay I was like
I'm great in the theater I'm great at a
comedy club
it's all me issues special I fall apart
at the seams I can't even think about it
yeah yeah but if I don't have to shoot
you know comics all our young comics
listening to this right now you know how
hard it is to get a tape like this whole
career this whole business is based on
tape share sensation you can't get for
the next level without a table there's
people who were just very smart comics
yeah yeah I wasn't smart
this comics would just buy a camera and
a tripod and just film every set and
they just keep filming they don't care
if it's three people many people sure
that's what they do they watch the set
it's training and they watch what they
did wrong but they're also hoping my
mistake yeah this is like a the want to
look at me yeah yeah you want to look at
me if you're me I don't look at me I
don't want everyone to see me up yeah
you got to get better that's how you're
better that's how you get better for
sure and that there's people that are
young comics today
I guarantee on all those people who have
really good specials like I could see
like an Anthony Jeselnik being a guy
that taped all sets and got so
comfortable that it's just second nature
I can't do all four specials come on
wish you a special debt will come see me
live I'll rock your [ __ ] world and in
my world that's what really matter what
you get what you need is somebody
somebody like bill must set without you
knowing that but who's filming without
you know I don't know that's the problem
well they don't pay somebody off know
what I you know you can't forget my
accounting club no more
you gotta get permission to put a camera
in there
if a calf of a dog I sees you going like
this they're gonna come to you and ask
you to leave I so you always have to be
prepared
that was my knock yeah I'm not good at
special yeah and then look at I tell you
who that happened to I'm not putting him
down I don't want either people to hit
him up on Twitter and said I would say
he was a shitty fighter I heard he was
the best you Jitsu guy at what's uh the
New York schools not myself
Enzo school David branch I heard David
branch was beating people throw them
through windows on bond bond people with
one arm [ __ ] fighting people with
with blindfolds he can't catch a break
he got beat up in the UFC yeah just got
beat up last week one flying champion
yeah man
there's people who fall between the
holes sure I've always said man I really
feel like I was like that kind of
fighter because I would go spar at jams
and [ __ ] people out and light him up and
people would just automatically assume
right that I would just kill everybody
and then I would [ __ ] like win one
lose one win one lose one and it was
just like it was like hot and cold man
it was like you're a Frank Trigg yeah
ever he's to commentate in the prize
right I liked him because he was real
blunt and like when he would say
something about a fire in a cage he was
like man this guy 50% of the time it
looks like he should be fighting the
biggest MMA show in the world and the
other 50% of time he should be eating
popcorn in the stands but the other
[ __ ] you know I mean and that's
that's what we're talking about and
that's kind of how I was like when I
would win and when I wouldn't think
about it and I would get in that zone I
would zip do people like that like I
would feel it like like I should be
fighting UFC and then another night I
would just like fall apart in there
I'm talking to myself in the cage while
I'm [ __ ] clinched with the
[ __ ] and stuff like that you
know what I mean so you wouldn't be
consistent I was not consist I was not a
consistent right that's a [ __ ] thing
it was like I said I had three three
professional losses in a row and that
was like that's it I'm done because what
happens is when you win man you it's
such an amazing feeling like [ __ ]
winning over a fight and somebody in the
cage and then people are coming up to
you you're the [ __ ] man they want
your autograph like when I want to built
in Mexico and then you keep searching
for that feeling again man that's why
people stay they retire they don't
retire soon enough you know what I mean
they keep fighting and keep fighting
because they because the feeling of
winning is just
it's amazing yeah I mean it's crazy we
actually a fire it up it's crazy when
you see a fighter or any professional
athlete that's done they don't know that
yeah yeah they don't want it they don't
want except the one except it but
they're done and you feel bad
yeah well when people say well I wish
this guy like escape from the UFC yeah
somebody like BJ Penn and you know like
[ __ ] a long time ago I hate seeing I
like why is he still fighting you don't
like that you know it's horrible it's
warm we lost seven in a row now why is
he still fighting you see there's no
need for his engine time we just switch
over this because you can't you can't
have that [ __ ] eye of the tiger
forever run you just can't happen how do
you it's good yeah it's kind of I kind
of understand it because if if you have
that mindset to be able to do it like
you can still have the mindset when your
body's not there so it's kind of hard to
turn that mindset off I would assume
yeah I mean you think you will
yeah well mindset is also built in
confidence sure my mindset first a
stand-up show or a wrestling match or
UFC fight is a different mindset and say
how you look at things when you're going
into it you know going to a gym for some
people it's really tough
sure go for a gym it's tough for me
sometimes but I go in there looking I
like it like I'm gonna eat [ __ ] yeah
you can eat some [ __ ] look at the gel
whatever we have to do to turn into a
positive upon like Conor that's that's
you know you know I could never like you
know like people consider me a funny guy
at legacy you know cuz I'm all I'm
always trying to I I just like having a
good time man but I could never see
myself they should do comedy man I'll
laugh I like being up on stage like you
do meant that I would [ __ ] my pants what
scares you about it like if people
aren't laughing I get booed off the
stage you know which is kind of silly
I've had I've gotten my ass kicked in
front of thousands of people but check
this out so I had like my first musical
performance you know and and I have a
singing instructor astana
and I had like maybe five lessons with
her and I hadn't been able to our times
where
matching up so I hadn't had anything
have been able to have any lessons with
her so I hadn't seen her in a couple of
months and I was about to take a nap and
she texts me she's like hey I want you
to perform in this performance that
Genghis Cohen my adrenaline went up I
was like oh [ __ ] I gotta [ __ ] I got I
was like I have to do this because it's
something I've always wanted to do you
know so I just [ __ ] him man I played
those songs but I did two original songs
I did them I practice them so much that
it was like second nature to me and then
what happened was like you like you're
saying was like that Genghis Cohen
Alberto was there with his wife and
there was like ten people were there
from legacy and man it just loosened me
up so well I did not even [ __ ] get
nervous dude but then I also had like a
backing band you know I mean so I had
something to fall back on
like with comedy is like there's nobody
back there like singing backup for you
or anything like that so it's [ __ ]
like it's [ __ ] crazy man you know I
don't want to end up like [ __ ] Kramer
from [ __ ] Seinfeld rumor he [ __ ]
got heckled and then [ __ ] lost it up
there well he said they went up then
said a bunch of [ __ ] ratio yeah yeah
yeah the guy was heckling so he was that
motherfucker's to it it doesn't matter
because I was looking on Google one time
and they always have like the top those
guys are still making [ __ ] there's a
dollar from santol they're making me sit
home counting his money yeah but what
good is if he's home with the windows
with the shades drawn that's true man if
you can't spend your money every time
you every three black guys he sees goes
[ __ ] [ __ ] on stage at the Laugh Factory
you know so it's gotta be tough for some
bill and yeah yeah for sure I mean I
respect like louis c.k I respect those
guys but then again I know what it's
like to come out of prison hmm and the
words out that you've been in prison
good to see you knowing and you have to
tell like where have you been how was it
in there I was [ __ ] Disneyland
it was Disney on Ice how the [ __ ] you
think it was and all that [ __ ] in life
but it's so weird how the mindset of
things you know even when I write comedy
I used to sit down and go I don't know
what I'm doing this because nothing
Goods gonna come on this now I look now
I look to write because I know the
longer I sit down I'm gonna get one line
I just will need one line cementum I
and they'll stay in there forever one
night he'll come out and I'll [ __ ]
die laughing they have but the mindset
especially you know we know the mindset
of them that I had between 94 and like
2012 was completely different the
mindset I have like it's a business for
me now sure I have to be good I have to
eliminate this there was a time when I
went on stage and I was 50/50 I was a
50-50 m7g I especially if I improvised
especially found what I think oh hey how
you guys doing that stuff what's your
name buddy what do you do for a living
I don't care about really what are you
swing um you hit people in the head with
them ha ha ha
that shit's terrible that's a horrible
[ __ ] way to do comedy sir not
preparation
yeah man eliminates a lot of that via
preparation Oaks for people and stuff
like that no no I mean no like what
that's what I did for the performance
men is like I I like I would invite
people on my pad I play songs for them
and stuff like that no I tell you go
[ __ ] yourself yeah you know what you
need to do you got to be like Conor
McGregor and you got a you got to turn
turn it into a positive
you got it you got to think like this
listen why am i this comedy club because
people are here and they want to see you
and they [ __ ] love you and they think
you're [ __ ] funny is [ __ ] you know I
mean just go out there and do your thing
you know how to do your thing you know I
mean that's how you got to like think
you should I look at it as got it you
should join people love these I've been
doing this for 20 years
yeah I've done the halftime of the
Buffalo Sabres hockey game and and
that's the confidence I get that I've
done this a foul
yeah yeah yeah for sure forget about
people I listen you love your mother but
if she slips up with the [ __ ] recipe
no mom what the [ __ ] with this you
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh you can't you can't be
on my looking [ __ ]
you can't be on oh hi mom where's the
[ __ ] laundry didn't wash my shirt you
I have a date tonight I didn't feel good
I still got skid marks in my drawers
yeah listen people love you but you are
trying to deliver the goods sure so I
have never rested laurels on that yeah
yeah
we listen to the podcast they paid for a
babysitter they paid for a ticket they
paid for a [ __ ] ticket service charge
they did a thousand things um to be here
I have to do a thousand things to be my
best for that where it's called my head
I'm the only thing I don't do is wear a
suit because I can't sell my material
with a suit
yes it's not you it's not it's not you I
would love a suit what state give
somebody you know in the 70s you wore a
suit to make people a man yet you know
you should you should do one of those
like suits like Eddie Murphy did in raw
that leather red leather suit Elvis when
half of how its opening out when they
got in wear a suit he came to a meeting
in shorts you sure the [ __ ] that was
like disrespectful I was hilarious
thousands you always had a suit on that
70s you always wore a suit the 70s when
you flew see that you were required to
wear a suit really all of these yeah
look at the planes in the seventies when
people flew everybody was dressed for
tonight only now these two people with
flip-flops and dirt on their heel
putting the shoes up on your [ __ ]
thing we've changed Eddie but flying has
become a nightmare also flying should be
an experience you know when you go on
vacation on vacation doesn't matter but
he's going in Mexico Mars Jupiter you're
going on vacation you wanted a plane
you're gonna be at the airport you don't
see a bunch of people what they do you
get to an airport they push on the
Communist line for two hours she bet you
don't know all of a sudden you thought
oh we gotta throw your shampoo away what
the [ __ ] I'm flying with no shampoo they
threw when my [ __ ] ear things yeah
you know oh what's these pills all those
are my pills in my sleep when your
domestic do they make you take your
shoes off and all that [ __ ] oh yeah
domestic flight and I got clear and they
still if you unless you got TSA
then you don't to take their shoes off
but like I'll fly with a warm-up suit
you need that like what does it call
that Global Entry [ __ ] you know Global
Entry
where you bypass all those customs and
all that [ __ ] and you can just go right
it's called Global Entry it's pretty
dope that's great but I got 19 felonies
like you don't qualify
alright I get TSA pre out of La huh
they always give it to me because I fly
20 times a year ain't no I'm not a
[ __ ] terrorist
it's the other plan it's the other
airports the computer systems don't give
me TSA pre plus I have to clear so I cut
right through you anyway nice I know how
to fly so I know not to wear jeans you
know you know what genius stuff now I
like to be comfortable you don't wear
like warm up so you have to put you take
your belt off you know you gotta wear
sneakers in case you got a run through
an airport you know you gotta wear flip
flip flip flops what if you gotta run to
an f1 there's an active shooter you also
have to have like easy access because in
case you catch you overcome a member of
the mile-high club always oh you know I
don't drink alcohol on a flight I don't
try to retain sodium last time I tried
yeah I did that was man before I got it
is so weird and how bad I feel even
before I well I take care of myself and
I fly like long distances I feel it for
a couple days I could imagine people
don't take care of themselves when they
fly how they feel I just ordered like
one of those tight pants the chick wear
yoga pants that's a spat someone start
wearing spats under the sweats I see a
lot of people wear those I believe I
don't like them who I was I hadn't worth
it
I had a worth of my leg for the
hamstring yeah yeah I can see that is
the blood clot I'll put them on both
legs I was like a lot of people put them
under there depends why your forget my
smile like stuck a little sprouts you
gotta like open it up [ __ ] with the
Roma I'll get nice and stuck in there no
it's mindset is really big with
everything you know a man when you get
into jujitsu when you walk in that door
the first three classes you realize
you're completely lost people Mountain
you people passing your guard you know
if you took a look at the percentages
people probably quit after four classes
because they don't think they gotta
achieve that there's people I go [ __ ]
it's hard
let me put my head down somebody's smart
like you goes up to mrs. come in you see
what's happening tonight it's gonna
happen for the next enjoy and he if you
keep coming here three times a week
you'll be doing with that door now I
tell people that a lot of people will
put their head down and do it exactly
that fight through whatever yeah commit
to it three times a week but you have to
explain to them that every time
everybody goes through the same process
tell people it's like when you start
jujitsu you have to master tap Jitsu
first to learn how to tap tap with your
foot say tap tap with your hands
whatever you know because you don't know
anything it's like learning a language
you know like I'm gonna give you a
couple moves it's like giving you a
couple of words and then later on you
learn how to put it into a sentence and
connect the connect the dots and all
that stuff like that's jujitsu it takes
it takes time just like anything else
people ask me how do I get better at
jujitsu I was like you got to do it more
just like anything you want to get good
at something you got to do it all the
time if you're doing jujitsu for like
once a week
you're not gonna retain anything twice a
week three times a week a little bit
better but you know what I mean you got
to just keep doing it man so like yeah I
go through that every day I have to
encourage people I even had a blue belt
once many he was on the couch at almost
in tears blue belt and he's an older guy
man great guy but man you know he's
getting smashed by all these young cats
and stuff like that he and he's like hot
professor man I'm I think I'm just gonna
[ __ ] quit I'm just gonna quit I get
my ass kicked every day and every day
there's no nose like listen man I had to
sit down and talk to him you know
because you know you people get the blue
belt blues man that's the cutoff point
blue belt people get their blue belt
they either drop off if you make it to
purple belt statistics say that you're
gonna eventually go to your black boat
so yes so I'm mad just exact exactly
like I see it
all the time I have to like encourage
people because people get discouraged no
you gotta work for this you take garlic
tabs yes and I took three cuz I wanted
to be special further than the hata
salad which pushes everything up
mmm-hmm take over for that how much
would it cost to get to have you sit
here and just choke about every time
when does this so I get loves that stuff
he's a real man doesn't mind looking for
three times faster what are those call
with this like Asian people where you
know like when they're sick I I gotta
I'm trying to build a contraption I'm
trying to take my sleep apnea machine
and figure out how to put it on people
and for it you know oh my god that's the
system oh my god
how are they sleep apnea man you don't
even know it's coming you just breathe
cuz there's nothing better than farting
and somebody walks into your fart and
catches a huge breath of it like you
know what might have I caught a manager
one night at a comedy club
I had just fart and he came in with his
mouth open oh my god I'm like looking at
me like a dick if I was you I wouldn't
stand there I know you already know you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] live that flower my god
you just walked into it he just walked
in a little and took a deep breath and
it was all over again how you know it's
so weird 2020s coming I know that's
crazy 26:1 we get you on to just talk to
people you know I tell people all the
time if you're thinking of doing
resolutions in your wait until January
first you lost already
yeah start right now yeah people like
this no because December give December
means 10 pounds people have no idea that
well man once you hit December it's 10
pounds no matter what I don't know what
it is man around this time here to suck
is crazy sweet sweets
they're everywhere [ __ ] sweet you
know yes they had a rough death but on
my cat away yeah yeah well [ __ ]
Luxton
I had to put him down and this is the
one I made the promise to the quick
cocaine I made a thousand promises to a
thousand people and the one I kept was
to a cat done didn't even know he made a
problem I just got on my hands and knees
and said God if you save this cat I'll
never snort coke again
I had to put him down yesterday
and my wife got back at that I didn't
feel too good when she left I thought I
thought I was having a stroke because I
got up late laying on the floor with him
until they took him and I hadn't eaten
and I got up just to make a protein
shake and I made a wrong protein shake I
have a mayonnaise Oh like I did [ __ ] I
don't even know what I put in it I put
the wrong I don't even put milk in
protein I wouldn't make a protein shake
or water huh
type of milk and ice cream I know what
am i doing that's how this shoveled I
was I had a starter scratch but what she
got back she does what he wanna do when
I go listen I know you're too upset they
cooked got a couple pieces of sushi and
when we walked out she wasn't your happy
and I god I feel a little better
and she goes what would make you happy
and I go honest to god something that I
haven't had since I started you Jitsu or
anything
she goes what cycle a piece of apple pie
just because I'm petrified of diabetes
petrified professor so I saw this one
over the 4:20 and we splitted the chapel
pile and ice cream you know that was the
extent of it but yeah usually I watched
myself a lot in December yeah because
those cookies add up yeah man I I don't
typically eat Akane's
I think the box of candy canes if you
let me come on you're watching the news
you know one candy cane you know I know
what's going on now - is his parents are
bringing like yes freshly baked cookie
and they're putting him on the table
right there
and yes I can't [ __ ] just look at him
man no you gotta watch myself this time
really I typically don't eat sweets I
don't keep any sweets in my pad because
I'll [ __ ] get I'll get stoner
munchies and I'll [ __ ] fit some box
of cookies or I'll eat the whole box so
I don't even keep anything my pad that I
I have to cook everything you know make
sure have to cook it otherwise I'll get
like the munchies any other [ __ ] but
it's funny cuz yesterday sick my points
for the day a 41 that's what I'm allowed
and yesterday 860
thank God you have like extra points to
dip into but I hate the holidays man no
I hate 60 because the pipe ice cream
yeah yeah almost like pure sugar but it
was
you know you gotta watch yourself this
time do you get a lot of new students
now in the first uh like usually in the
new year you know that's that's what
like you said everybody has the
revolutions resolutions and everything
and then people pile in you know but I
mean like geez mer we already have so
many students there but we have people
coming there all the time but around the
new year that's you know we usually do a
special and absolutely we get people who
haven't been there in a while come back
and then you get new people that come
back come in you know with the
resolutions and stuff like that but I
agree with you man is like you know what
don't like don't use that as a crutch
you know if you want to get a shake just
[ __ ] start now get in shape and just
do it and you know don't wait hubs gonna
do it to the new year man so I try to
never stop like working out you know I'm
always doing that I can respect what you
do you post your videos every day win
places show you know yeah you're showing
people the flow you're doing you explain
the flow of the week yeah yeah exactly
no I mean you have a really really good
system over I appreciate it man I gotta
like be [ __ ] swinging no kettlebells
for an hour though yeah well we don't
swing the kettlebell for an hour man we
always warm up what we always do
mobility your class consistent if I get
that 5:30 if you got there at 5:30 5:30
at 5:30 you're gonna come in we're gonna
do mobility which is which is like neck
rotations shoulder rotations elbow
rotations hip rotations you know get
those get the blood flowing in the
joints and stuff like that it's
something that I did I never used to do
before but like as like in my late 30s I
started getting injuries and I was just
like man I'm not warming up enough so
especially like as we get over we got to
get blood flowing into those joints and
stuff like that you know so we do that
it's a really for the first like like 20
25 minutes of the class
it's all very low impact like isometric
stuff like planks and stuff like that
then we get into some body weight
training and it gets a little bit more
intense a little bit more intense and
then the like last 30 minutes of the
classes when we start getting into the
kettle but little by little so like
whenever you see the video that I post
that's like very not already warmed up
already built okay already built up
today I'm like if I gotta walk in that
first day then you just hit me with a
figure off
that's a hottie how'd you you I would be
hurting everybody and I wouldn't have
anyone in my class man so like it's like
when people come to the gym man it's
it's my priority to keep them safe if
I'm hurting people in my kettle bell
class nobody's gonna come I won't have a
[ __ ] job I've been [ __ ] teaching
kettlebell classes for ten years man you
know and and uh that's really what
separates me from all these Instagram
kettlebell flow people you know because
if you look at them they're not training
anybody when do you ever see me post a
video of me just working out by myself
you know is they're working out by
theirself because they're not training
with anybody that's why I don't like
working out by myself working out with
my students it's more fun you know I
practice what I preach but it's very
very you're not there with a whistle I
watch no no no I will use a dry erase
board or anything all my workouts are in
my head I know my work my own program
you know like the back of my hand but um
yeah like safety is key I never forced
somebody to use too much weight that
they're they're not comfortable with I'm
like hey how is that weight is it too
heavy we can go lighter if it's too
light you know I mean to me in the
beginning it's more about technique and
then it's really about what you want to
do you know like if you want to progress
and gradually you have to start
increasing the weight if you want to get
a little bit stronger you have to
increase weight a little bit but even
then I don't go super heavy mode I'm
like I'm not really into doing like max
reps and stuff like that it's because
when you start going heavier and you
start doing max reps then you're pushing
yourself to do more weight than your
body's accustomed to and then that's
when people start getting injury because
you start losing form and stuff like
that and another reason people get
injured too is because they don't warm
up enough so if you're really warm and
you don't go too heavy then chances are
you're not gonna get hurt doing primary
focus kettlebell
it's strength or cardio or both it's
supposedly
in my classes usually O'Toole yeah I get
like in my class you're gonna get you're
gonna get strong and you're gonna you're
gonna burn a ton of calories as well you
know uh so you're gonna get strong
because I always practice in every class
you got to think about the movements
that we do in everyday life what do we
do we squat down and pick up stuff so we
squat we do lunging we hinge we push we
pull and we do some rotational stuff so
if you're working those movements
like with resistance and stuff in body
weight then you're gonna build
functional strength if you combine those
movements and do like compound movements
that involve multiple motions like
squatting and pressing like safer so you
get a kettlebell you squat and you press
that's a call it's called a thruster
you're working your whole body together
so you're developing strength that way
as well
you're also developing muscle endurance
and stuff like that so there's different
ways to get strong now the thrusters
that's when you squat squat on the way
up throw it up so like st. Francis
CrossFit people they do thrusters with
the barbell that means they squat and
then at the top
don't press and you squat and you're
press so you just work in air it's a
fantastic exercise with kettlebell you
have like a bunch of different
variations because you could do it with
one kettlebell you can do one kettlebell
rack in one hand you could do it with
two kettlebells you can add a twist to
the punch at the top of the thrusters so
that's why I like kettlebells because
allows for a lot more natural movement
and and I don't go on a go super heavy
man I don't really believe in in in a
you know I think a lot of people lift
really heavy because it makes them feel
confident you know it makes them feel
that they're strong and stuff like that
but I'm a [ __ ] fighter man you know
we get 220 pound guys come in and I can
roll them up because I know jiu-jitsu so
like how much weight you live I really
don't doesn't it's it doesn't matter to
me you know I mean because I know like
later on in life like when you get our
age is stuff like you're not gonna be
[ __ ] trying to [ __ ] deadlift
[ __ ] 500 pounds and [ __ ] like that
you know you got to think about
sustainability and stuff like that so
like when it comes to killable work man
I think maybe my main bill that I use
most of the time is like a 16 kilogram
kettlebell it's just dirty 230 it's like
32 yeah something like that listen go
with ya for swinging I'll probably do
like maybe like 24 kilograms stuff like
I don't go super heavy man I don't feel
like I need to it's just for me it's
just supplemental training to to add to
my regular jujitsu training and stuff
like that it's just a supplement to keep
muscles dry that most of the training is
based on a bloke what's his name no no
no the Russian was a devil Pavel I don't
even think he's Russian but um he like
see a lot of people
he invented cannibal tarnish has been in
[ __ ] Russia forever man you know and
and you know what's funny about
kettlebell training is nobody there's
not a clear history of kettlebell
training but Pavel gets credit because
he's really the person who brought
kettlebells to America and popularized
it you know but he has a whole different
philosophy around like his thing is like
like my original kettlebell coach was
certified from Pavel but they have this
whole thing where you are a guy you must
swing with 40 kilos and the Mayans
started be like do your MMA fighter you
should be swinging with this much and
when I was I did my back is [ __ ] a
hurting room after class I'm like why
like I realized we wouldn't warm up but
that's how he teaches if you see his
video like he has this one videos like
if you are not tough we make you tough
you got to see the video it's like all
it's almost like a joke man you know
like personally I have never been a
really big fan of that guy you know but
he has his own philosophy he was just on
Joe Rogan show you know Pavel you got it
you gotta check it out for yourself he
wouldn't tell her Joe Rogan asked him
how old he was did you see that no no
that guy right there you could see Joe
got turned off because he was like hey
so how old are you and he goes I'm 20
and he's like oh because no but really
how old are you and then he wouldn't
tell Joe Rogan his age and Joe runs a
I'm 52 are you older than me or younger
man and he was he was giving Joe the
runaround he wouldn't flip and do it so
jugular Joe Rogan was like some of this
guy you know and then you know what's
funny is um somebody a student explains
something to me he was like man you
should be as famous as these guys and
this guy's he's like but what happens is
these guys they know how to hack
something they figure out how to get
like marketing and stuff like that they
find the marketing niche right there and
then boom they blow up but I study
people man I see if somebody says
they're this and then that I research
him and I to be honest with you I've
never seen that guy actually workout
with the kettlebell
I've seen him demonstrating kettlebell
exercises and stuff but I've never seen
him do an actual workout like an
hour-long workout now if you look up
somebody like Steve Carter or Steve
Maxwell who are my early influences of
kettlebell training those guys were
always working out with [ __ ]
kettlebells they're always training
people that's why I like those guys live
okay these guys are the
[ __ ] I love Steve max I love like those
Steve Maxwell Steve Carter those are two
like n fu training kettlebells you
should research the og cats like that
those guys were doing it before us those
guys were originally rkc people but they
you know philosophies differ so they
broke off and did their own thing
but that's the guys know their [ __ ] and
so like for instance whenever I first
started learning kettlebells from one of
those rkc guys they talk about the
snatch like it's the best kettlebell
exercise in the world oh if you can
snatch a hundred times your jujitsu is
just gonna go through the roof but not I
would do the snaps I was like come on
man it's a core based movement it's not
gonna make your Jiu Jitsu better you
know and I don't think I don't feel like
it's a street a true test of strength
but back to Provo last night on Joe
Rogan show he was asking us also what
kind of workouts do you do you know what
he told Joe Rogan he said I do swings
and dips only that's all he does and Joe
Roma's you don't do anything else he's
like no because I think I feel those
exercise cover everything swings so
swing if you still swing it as swing is
a hinging movement so you're primarily
working your your butt your hamstrings
your abs your lower back and you know
you get a little bit of a full body
workout but man it's not the be-all and
end-all there are so many other
movements that you should really focus
on you know not just swings and dips and
the dips what do you work and your work
in your lower chest you're working your
triceps working your shoulders you know
your core a little bit but but I thought
I I'm like I'm glad he said that because
he teaches everybody all this kettlebell
stuff and barbell stuff yet he doesn't
even do it himself you know I mean
that's why I'm like I'm glad he said
that because there you go right there
he's because back in a day or even
remember back in the day in martial art
magazines they were not advertised he
would advertise in the magazines the
kettlebell is the ak-47 of the Russian
Spetsnaz make you strong like Russian
spits no you know like stuff like it and
I was just like give me a [ __ ] break
man and then then he goes on drove in
last night and talks about how he only
does two things so he doesn't do all the
statues and stuff like that you know
what I mean so that to me is it's not
authentic you know what I mean when I
get off a plane now on a Sunday
I do reset this wings huh
three sets of cleans that's a whole
nother thing you could probably do a
half a turn you could probably do a knee
if you're not doing vibe on the side
three times that's a great exercise no
it's it and by the way like that I feel
completely better I yes you funny bring
you the Turkish getup though man is like
I have to had to stop calling the
Turkish getup
because at Legacy we have like a ton of
Armenian people and it just was not
[ __ ] jiving with the man they're like
[ __ ] that I'm not gonna [ __ ] do that
[ __ ] I'm gonna do a [ __ ] Armenian get
up and I get it man you know what I mean
get out more like [ __ ] so my real
self-conscious about saying that now so
I just call it the the kettlebell get up
now but it's a great exercise and it's
it's very specific to jujitsu because
the Turkish getup is basically the same
thing is what we call the technical
lifts in jujitsu and you're gonna use
that movement like if you roll you're
gonna use something that looks like the
Turner's you get up multiple times
within that rule so it that is a great
exercise I definitely recommend people
learning the kettlebell get up we just
sort of engaged you just have I'm
actually gonna be in Texas in March
March 14 gonna be in a place called
rides kickboxing I'm going to be doing a
four-hour workshop there and then
shortly after that I'm gonna have a
certification here in Burbank I just saw
that there was it go somebody took a
picture like in France hmm well your
students open up a school in France or
something
student they got certified by you
whatever the [ __ ] you certified them and
they went on to open up a school uh-huh
and they sent you like a little video
wasn't a girl yeah doing the roles yeah
oh that's that she's gonna be stoked
about that this is set her her handle
I'm just kind of out power powerful so
she reposted a workout that I did I like
a judge it's a specific bodyweight flow
yeah so like yeah I'm at school Amanda
how followers all over the world is
pretty cool man when people do that it's
very flattering I dig it man you know
somebody in the other side of the world
is doing your [ __ ] you know but like she
came back she came she's been following
my workouts she purchased my downloads
online so then when she was in town she
came in she got like a couple private
lessons for me so
she understands and she's a she's
already a trainer and she trains people
as well so yeah that's that's what
you're talking about man man you're I
don't even see you on Instagram half the
time but you're on there man you're
scoping people that watch you're
watching man you just want you to learn
like watch a movie you're like a ninja
no you're just like watching i watch it
people do wrong under the scrim on
social make sure people do right I'm
learning yeah yeah man wanted to see
that you post on Saturday what kind of
results to see yet yeah yeah you have to
see where your social media is in your
world and you're doing a great job with
it and I appreciate it man you know I do
it because I love it man I you know
honestly I don't like social medias it's
kind of a pain in the butt but we got to
do it you know and I always feel like I
have to be posting things but you know
I'm happy to be doing it for a living
man well it's not about what you think
about what you do for people absolutely
go on Facebook at nine in the morning
and already you go yeah yeah that's why
that's the way I look every minute video
up don't pee but maybe I need to work
out a little bit today yeah I get that
all the time to go to Hollywood I got to
do this I won't have time to go [ __ ]
Mikey I get that people here yeah I see
you training at 5:30 let me do five sets
of swings yeah you know make sure you
warm up first I think like [ __ ] like
if you look at it okay just to let you
know people at all if you do let's say
kickboxing oh you do kickboxing for 15
minutes
you burned eight points with Weight
Watchers but if you do
without your Weight Watchers and app
kettlebell workout for 15 minutes
you burn 10 points huh nothing burns
more calories than swings I think its
wings and swimming so I can see yeah
swing swings like been swimming but if
they say to kettlebell workout it could
mean a bunch of different things yeah
okay well it says no no if you well I
can I put down when I do my little 3 3 &
3 it's 10 minutes and you just use like
a light kettlebell 35 I don't there's no
reason to go but before I even met you
guys Lee and I went to a kettle bell
class where the guy would have you
strung an 85-pound ask and I would do it
on Tuesday and I couldn't do nothing
till Friday yeah yeah it's the law of
diminishing returns exactly what kettle
bell that's why I gonna do something
twice I'm not doing I'm not hitting see
that's like that what's that guy that
for John Jacques the white dude that has
in jiu-jitsu school years ago Ron Wood
Wood Roy something Roy Harris oh yeah
right I remember I read his jujitsu
thing and it was brilliant about why
schools aren't doing this and this he
goes and I thought something Vinny
megaliths told me about a month ago
because Vinny CBD line was looking to
get somebody from pfl huh and I called
Vinny for something yeah and it was
funny that Roy Harris Roy Harris was the
one that really made me start thinking
about what am i doing would you Jitsu
because he goes listen when you're over
40 the rules are completely changed and
he goes that's what the problem is today
that when you're over 40 you go to a
jiu-jitsu class and you feel inadequate
because the 20 year olds are kicking the
[ __ ] out whatever you know your
testosterone starts to decrease and a
certain age and he goes I treat my forty
year olds and over completely different
than I do that's why they have like the
masters training Sundays you know he was
saying that but the Masters only Sundays
at 8 a.m.
sort of [ __ ] kills you that's the
only time that I'm either out of town or
who the [ __ ] is up with a that works out
of a [ __ ] yeah you know I'll eight
o'clock
my house and it's still like it's still
for this this is tremendous golly way oh
this is the route sometimes you get a
fourth this Italian garlic part it's
tremendous look he's all happy oil down
the floor other hamstring drive to
Ontario just cuz you [ __ ] my
hamstring I know the moving [ __ ] [ __ ]
eat six of those pills blow your [ __ ]
eyebrows off head young my farts will
[ __ ] burn those eyebrows again Bob
[ __ ] vodka Shh
so now that one's eat that and that's
what I'm saying like if you're looking
to really make a splash you know contact
professor let's say you live in I or
something just get yourself a 35-pound
Dumbo and contact professor Joey I'll
get them [ __ ] what I say dumbbell
about whatever the [ __ ] you know I'm
saying that yeah yeah well they sing the
thing the thing the thing you thought
yes please know what I taught you
the thing with the arm bar used to go
that's what a Kimura I don't [ __ ]
know what L mean that thing that wasn't
the Kimura that was a common gogoplata
omoplata funny and I got more plotters
than [ __ ] anything as I said look up
Joey I'll go out on Instagram what do
you put your work at that integrand yes
grandma Facebook everything then why
preach are you coming on man always come
out of here can I give a shout-out to my
my sponsor as a kettlebell King yes
always hooking old words s kettlebells
and Rogin still watches your stuff he's
crazy if I wanna I want to give that guy
a workout sometime
[ __ ] I like that over 50 we can't do
that complete [ __ ] cattle thing but
I'm happy you came in listen I want to
let people know 2020s coming I don't
agree with people whining that well we
live in a fucked-up society you know
Barbie should be fat no she shouldn't
Barbie shouldn't be fat cuz you're fat
you're a fat [ __ ] the sheet that's why
the same way with me I wish I look like
the guy from [ __ ] Aquaman we all do
but you're not just born like that yeah
you've got on to the doctor to take a
couple shots but you still lift weights
and go to the [ __ ] gym yeah the main
thing I've learned work healthy problem
yeah just being healthy get your blood
going did you buy something that you
enjoy doing something you enjoy doing
and go for it's 2020 that's it you said
they're all [ __ ] you thinking about
what you were gonna do and at the end of
the day then do dick yeah you didn't do
dick so it's over you gotta that's why I
love mondays I tell people all the time
Monday is my favorite day a week you
know why cuz you get a second chance at
everything
comedy jujitsu boxing eatin [ __ ]
licking [ __ ] sucking dick
let's say you got a Friday you don't do
a good job that's why people like your
Monday motivation man's like it's all
about my boy wider I told you about the
kidnapping he's like tell him tell Joey
I loved his Monday March all about it
Thank You laughs and I guess you're out
like [ __ ] up how can you get ready
listen to Joey dominating the suckin
dick top thing you're walking around I'm
having a gloomy day yeah take that dick
out and go on the [ __ ] hunt also let
me let me say something to people like
you know how people get really depressed
over the holidays and stuff like that
man you know how to student recently
talk to me
you know that's what I think about being
a professor's like they confide in you
my rabbi when I was there with you
everything I tell you the truth yeah but
man you got to keep your head up man you
know you always got a you know if you
have a roof over your head and you have
food man you know you got to stay
positive and and you got to just
overcome that and just don't let don't
let the holidays get to you and stuff
like that man my mom my mom was her
birthday's on Christmas Day my brother
that rest in peace to his birthday was
three days after he was like murdered
like six years ago you know so like but
now it happens man you know but it's
life we have to move on and we have to
you know just do what we love in life
and just stay positive man you know in
2020 don't think about what you don't
have exactly about what you do have
exactly and how [ __ ] lucky you are
exactly you see somebody god forbid in a
wheel
and you complain and go [ __ ] yourself
put yourself in his [ __ ] shoes like
that you little [ __ ] [ __ ] now cut
the [ __ ] out listen I don't know
Alvarado and was the uncle Joy real
quick the church is brought to you by
policy genius are you coming for life
insurance not why would you you don't
think that way neither did I at 38 but
if you start now before you start
slipping and you have a pre-existing
condition everything works out what
happens if you slip on a banana peel
where'd you get your kids to ask to go
to school if you're not covered already
put life insurance at the top of your
to-do list policy genius makes it quick
and easy find the right life insurance
at the best price with policy genius
they do all the legwork and you get
covered go to policy genius calm right
now in minutes you compare quotes and
get the best possible price with policy
genius you can save up to $1,500 a year
don't be a [ __ ] dummy right
once you apply they handle all the
paperwork and the red tape policy genius
doesn't stop at life insurance either
think it'll be open homeowners insurance
auto insurance and disability listen to
pay the asking insurance it really is in
today's world policy genius makes it
nice and easy so if you need life
insurance head to policy genius if we
need home insurance head to policy
genius if you need disability insurance
at the policy genius doctor home right
now it'd take only takes a few minutes
to find the right insurance company for
you and the right life insurance policy
apply and have another thing crossed off
your list in 2020 policy genius when it
comes to life insurance it's nice to get
it right and tell them the church or
what's happening now sent you there
another gift you could do for yourself
over the holidays athletic greens Joey
what's that letting greens listen it's
vitamins can you imagine starting your
day off with a blast of vitamins who's
gonna stop you
nobody if you want to feel tip-top Magoo
letteth let the Greens do the work with
one scoop you get 75 essential vitamins
minerals probiotics prebiotics digestive
enzymes
and wrong superfoods and Whole Foods
they got everything
no more pill bottles or trying to choke
down a dozen apples it's all in one pack
me I use the Travel Pack when I'm on the
road or luath letting greens is like a
daily life insurance you know I'm not
there in New York on all these place
everybody fine I'm going I'm getting you
know new germs thrown at me so I want to
be double [ __ ] sure when I'm on the
road so I pop a little inch ah let's let
it greens with some water and it's got
everything in there its plant-based if
you're on keto gluten no chemicals no
other official flavor there's no other
fishing preservatives no artificial
sweeteners the added sugar no GMOs
herbicides pesticides wheat dairy gluten
corn lactose sucrose ducros egg yeast
Peter 2 animal products these guys are
by the book and legit guys you need to
take care of yourself and that's why I
recommend supplements to everybody it's
easy just add cold water and shake it up
that's it you can take that banana and
shove it up your ass
what are you waiting for listen the
church family you get 20 free travel
packs value that $79 with your first
purchase so do me a favor go to athletic
greens calm right now
slash church to get your travel pack
that's athletic green calm slash church
I want to thank athletic greens I want
to thank policy genius for having our
back but most importantly I want to
thank you [ __ ] savages for listening
next week's Christmas guess what you
ain't got time to be depressed will be
here with your [ __ ] yeah I want
to thank professor joy Alvarado thank
you over at Legacy go catch him he's got
a 5:30 a.m. class a 6:30 p.m. class
during the week Tuesdays and Thursdays
and I think it's 11:00 on Saturday 10:00
a.m. 10:00 a.m. on Saturdays go visit
them and tell them I sent you besides
that have a great [ __ ] weekend enjoy
yourself shopping go to Amazon do your
last shopping use the Church of what's
happening now link and that's it and
that's that yeah I want to thank you
guys and I want to wish you all a happy
holiday season and Hanukkah is around
the corner for you [ __ ] Jews
ready sharpen that dick and put some
[ __ ] grease on your shoes it's time to
slip and sue somebody I'm saying anyway
I love you [ __ ] happy holidays